give up this is over October on banks if
I see tomorrow partly due to social film
soup can effectively when steam just a
blah just a move on come on happy
Wednesday never see after the safina 60
demo Jovi we don't fit friendship come
on come on Anna translate I promise you
I translated afterwards I promise you
translate the Christ view he actually
think about yeah I want to read feel
yeah and how Harvey Weinstein went you
know to this film from can to what it is
today if you don't mind so in Frenchman
our promise you I translated afterwards
I understand so answer in English yes
the questions very long laptops to
doggy when's teens get out of there
surfing what did Harvey Weinstein bring
to this phone is wait
it is the biggest in the end of this
year you can find in the US he's always
been supporting not only French movie
but what he came through you know we
were totally unknown here and he went to
see a movie silence like your life with
except American cast and it's all these
online gratis visual will not go here
and he thought something was worth to
fly and he came to see the movie any
luck during the whole movie and then we
diddled just making job not alone he has
a great people with it people that work
with him up great and they voted they
did so that we were good today the pair
of you are the moment I have nothing bad
savor oh nothing just are actually a
pair of you have obviously this movie in
times i must be you guys how surprised
are you by the huge amount of attention
and every single award this moving is
why in the last that's way
so how surprised doctors right yeah well
it's for us it's just every time we come
on Sarah mini especially this one of
course it's just amazing as I said we
kept going to try to finish this movie
and a bit very short meeting and people
were you need to be done yes well
sounding like but what's your next
budget and I'm doubly welcome here of
this one so then people told me this is
against conventional wisdom this today
so we managed to from the money that we
wanted to shoot here in Hollywood
because we wanted to have a chance of
people like gems like Penelope we wanted
to have the chance to have great oh and
Richard here produce agree with us and
help us and we have the right sets I
mean everything was perfect for the
movie this movie was an hour we shall
defeat was made to be a tribute to
Hollywood to cinema especially to
American singer and the best place to do
it was to do in here so to come back
after the shoot and be here and be
rewarded by the Hollywood community
adjusted really come true
let you get people
no magic
imagine we can still find magic in the
movie
as a million yes when I got to my sis
imagine and when you make a movie you
try to try to do your best to cover
story and if it works do if you're very
lucky and if you hire the talented
person and can pick people i mean if the
stars are in a good combination you can
find something edgy matches I'm not sure
can because they're easy thing to do
the next film we might need you to go
yours maybe I'll coming or going back to
Paris if your next home that we make up
in America there's other country America
in Paris so I think it will be some of
this you know for the country Michelle
so you're just learning from France back
to that again how exhausting has a
trainer for the last three months
collection let's go well it's not the
worst job you can find you can receive
awards people smiling with me and
everyone is nice and people say you're
talented and you're a nice guy you're
very funny transaction excellent lesson
so you and we can here we have with the
police escort to come from vehicle that
was great that is the best part I can
get to ask for another one Polly system
and now it is it's physically styling
but the energy was so good that you
don't really feel
having unusual really thank you and we
were enjoying every director tonight I
have two years for graciously i think
has in from the session oh he got to he
thought that I where I did john de
Chardin and cinematography I was going
to say is she hiding it under the dress
and she get to take it home with do it
obviously not sure that's it the other
person right now people are your big
night
I think I'm really good stage fright
yeah because this is something that we
have you in the vi phone or a long time
so I can't say I'm super cool but today
I mean this is important to whether so
because that this means a lot because
because it's a small movie and it's it's
not expensive we did it with smoke money
and an exact in my hands I easy to say
it small my around burning it are we
telling when the Aastra they make it
when Harley how we know how to produce
things like that sometimes is resonant
well versed and it's just the other take
the movie could do well all over the
world and he was right I mean we did it
we drink
you were silent the mainstream that was
really what we wanted and you cannot do
a mainstream another distributor and
someone are kind of out front of the
texting me and brings it all over the
world and everybody knows in friends and
if you're looking for someone good to
promote the movie better looks young
that's true
shoes
the environment initial comedy
James is probably the expert on the ones
i haven't had to say about that i do
believe in environmental care and
protecting our that I have two small
children give this day the ocean to
incredible charity and your Marin ocean
I'm afraid to spoon it so I hope that
this will bring awareness to that that
I'm sure James pillow
oh it's what police award celebrates
independent voices to address these
issues it seems to me that the
commercial media and this industry
neglect to inform their audience about
the seriousness of what we face
environmentally the degradation of our
environment and the cost it's going to
have not only on us and in future
generations but on the survival of the
species so I if any one of these films
gets the attention of those people who
can make a large budgeted films for
millions and millions of dollars and
that will reach a greater audience to
inform them that they better we better
start doing something about this
environment or we won't have a planet so
I I celebrate the independence awards
and those artists who can we address
this issue
regulation
Oh